good afternoon everyone i'm happy to be
here to provide today's updates on
covid19 and let me begin with our latest
numbers
i'm pleased to share that almost all our
indicators continue to trend downward
after a difficult fifth wave that
brought so much uncertainty over the
past few months this is very welcome
news
over the last 24 hours we have
identified 791
new cases of coven 19 and completed
about 2 800 tests
this puts our positivity rate for lab
confirmed cases
at about 27 percent
which is nearly a 14 drop since last
week
there are 11 189
active cases in the province and that
number has also been decreasing
in fact there are 68 percent fewer
active cases today compared to the
beginning of february sadly over the
past 24 hours 13 new deaths were
reported to alberta health
i extend my deepest condolences and
sympathies to the families and friends
of those albertans
another declining trend is a number of
schools that have had to shift to online
learning to address operational
challenges
albert education has confirmed that as
of today there are no schools
in temporary at-home learning
looking to hospitalizations
one week ago there were 1500 albertans
in hospital which
that
with or due to coven 19
including 121 in icu
today there are a total of
1373 in hospital including 90 in icu
this decrease is a positive sign that
pressure is easing on our health care
system and hopefully a beginning of
relief for our hard-working health care
workers
they're under strain and i feel for them
and i am grateful to them
but even with the strain they've been
under for the past two years
they continue to do a remarkable job for
the patients that they serve
ahs is currently completing about 95
percent
of normal surgical volume
and my department and i are supporting
them to get back to 100
as soon as possible and then to go even
higher
and it's not just surgery
our dedicated health care staff are
keeping the system working at high level
in other areas as well
in cancer care patients are getting
access to treatment within about the
same time that they did before the
pandemic
even in continuing care where there's
been a particular strain on the
workforce services are there
for patients waiting in hospital for a
continuing care bed the average wait
time is actually shorter now than it was
before the pandemic
our continuing care staff and operators
are working incredibly hard to maintain
access
and your government is working hard to
support them
the health system is still there for
patients who need it
and it's a strong foundation to build on
as we get past the omicron wave
and work to improve access and wait
times
and reduce wait times not just restore
the system to the level we had before
the pandemic
but give albertans better access to
surgery diagnostic tests and other care
right across our health care system
as we look towards our next stage in
easing measures i know that some
albertans continue to be concerned about
protecting themselves from covet 19
but the science is clear the single most
effective way to protect ourselves and
each other is by getting vaccinated and
this includes ensuring albertans
continue to get their booster shots
in alberta while 86.8 percent of the
adult population has received at least
two doses of the vaccine
only 44.9 percent has received a third
dose
that means there are still hundreds of
thousands of people who haven't yet
received one
we need to close the gap to help keep
hospitalizations low
as we prepare to further ease measures
so if you haven't gotten your butcher
shot yet i encourage you to do so today
one of my key priorities is to get our
vaccination coverage higher and that
includes removing barriers to receiving
vaccines
as well as answering questions and
urging people to make the choice to get
vaccinated if they haven't done so yet
teams at alberta health and alberta
health services continue to look for
ways to make getting vaccinated easier
for albertans of all ages
currently 47.2 percent
of children and youth have received at
least one dose and only 24 percent have
received two doses
we believe that by easing the burden on
working parents and guardians of booking
arranging and getting to vaccination
appointments we'll see an increase in
the number of young albertans between
the ages of 5 and 11 years
who are protected against covet 19.
that's why i'm pleased to announce that
we're increasing the options at the 97
ahs clinics offering
offering pediatric vaccine across the
province
for march 2nd to 16
ahs clinics across the province will
offer walk-in options including evenings
and weekends with some clinics beginning
to offer walk-in doses starting this
week
the clinics will operate from 3 pm to 8
pm monday to friday and noon till 6 pm
on saturday and sunday
after march 16
demand will be assessed to determine if
the expanded services should be
continued
that being said appointments are
encouraged and will still be honored at
all ahs clinics
in addition i am pleased to announce
that there will be more pharmacies
offering pediatric vaccines
to create additional access points for
albertans to have their children
vaccinated
17 pharmacies and rural communities will
be offering pediatric vaccines and will
add pharmacies in edmonton calgary
red deer lethbridge grand prairie
medicine hat and fort mcmurray
approximately 150 pharmacies will be
asked to participate based on their
experience in immunizing children and
they'll be ready to start as early as
march the second
finally i'm pleased to say that a number
of physicians will also be helping to
vaccinate the youngest eligible
albertans from march 2nd to the 16th
about 30 physicians have expressed
interest in administering vaccines and
their office will begin to receive
supply soon
and any other family physicians
interested in participating will also be
eligible to provide children's vaccines
i know that many albertans continue to
weigh the pros and cons of vaccinating
their kids and i hope that increased
availability helps to make this decision
easier
as we near the two-year milestone of
covid arriving in alberta i want to
recognize what an incredibly challenging
couple of years it has been for everyone
the current omicron wave is passing
and we and other jurisdictions are
returning to a more normal life
but i urge albertans to continue to
follow the rules that are still in place
this is especially critical in
continuing care settings where enhanced
measures will remain in place even once
we're into step two
please respect those rules and do your
part to help keep those vulnerable
residents safe
while they receive the care that they
need
we want to continue to support each
other through this transition and that
means respecting each other's choices
and accepting that people will
transition at their own pace
so thank you and i'll now happy to take
questions
thanks minister we've got a couple
reporters on the phone so uh we'll go to
the first caller please
the first caller is kerry tate from
global mail please go ahead
hi thanks for taking my call minister
i'm wondering if you have a goal for
childhood vaccination rates in light of
the
push in march
yeah we haven't set a specific target
but we would like to increase it and and
you know move closer and even achieve
the average across the country
we do know that you know when initial
surveys were done
you know
roughly one-third of the parents in
alberta were interested in getting their
kids vaccinated we've surpassed that but
i do know that you know when we compare
ourselves to other jurisdiction uh we
are one of the lowest in the country uh
and i'd like to actually you know reach
the the average for uh for the country
and this is one step in that direction
is providing easier access for parents
to get their kids vaccinated
thanks minister follow-up carrie
sure minister why do you think albert uh
parents in alberta are more reluctant
yeah
really great question um you know we've
seen that before and even in terms of
the initial surveys that were done that
there was tend to be more more reluctant
i i think honestly some parents are
taking a a wait and see attitude in
terms of you know we'll uh we'll see you
know how the rollout goes
and i also understand that some parents
um who have seen you know their kids get
uh coveted with the omicron wave which
has been so prevalent throughout the
province um at this point time may be
saying okay i'm going to hold back if
they haven't gotten vaccinated but again
i would you know urge all parents at the
best protection um even if someone has
actually had covet is to to get
vaccinated
and urge them to do so and and hopefully
the changes we announced here will make
it easier and increase the vaccination
rates
thank you
thanks minister we'll go to the next
question please
the first question is from elise tilty
tvc
please go ahead
hi minister it's actually a non-coveted
question for you sorry but um your
expert advisory panel last year
recommended a shift to more
community-based care for elders and
seniors your government has said it's
working on a plan to address that
can you tell me do you expect to see
significant changes this year on that
file and if so what should we be
watching for in tomorrow's budget
yeah so a couple of things um
you know as you know we did a
facility-based continuing care review
that was done last year uh government is
working on a response to that and you're
quite right as part of that review has
looked at more community-based care
and and also you know uh be able to
expand
our continuing care system so when we
moving forward
we we have legislation continuing care
legislation that we'll be introducing
this session
and that's going to help us renew our
reg our legal and regulatory framework
because right now we have different uh
acts that apply to
the continuing care setting um and it's
it's across the field it's very complex
and it's difficult to uh difficult to
manage so we're bringing that all under
one act and then over the course of the
next year our focus will be is getting
the regulations right
so we can actually move towards a policy
environment that supports care at home
because that's what we heard loud and
clear in addition um you know we we've
talked about before our need to support
the continuing care sector uh and and as
well as there's going to be an increased
demand um basically for more continuing
care spaces so i'm not going to jump the
gun for tomorrow but
you you will see a focus on us in terms
of expanding continuing care spaces uh
over the next year
thanks minister uh elise follow up
thanks yeah i appreciate that um
as you know with the and you mentioned
there's a capital investment that's been
recommended and that included some new
models like these small care facilities
at the same time advocates have been
working with your government to look at
what additional programs in the
community that seniors would need to
stay at home longer do you expect most
of the funding will be for experiments
and research in that area or are you
actually getting ready to roll out some
of these new programs and grant at a
larger scale this year
yeah so we'll have to wait for after the
budget but again our focus is on getting
the policy uh environment correct uh and
then looking at new model like capital
and then also looking at new models to
be able to provide services to albertans
particularly
those who would actually otherwise need
continuing care continuing care spaces
thanks minister so we had just three
callers uh initially so we'll we'll take
just one more the last of the three
next question is from kevin mimick ctp
calibri please go ahead
hi minister you announced new covet
deaths reported in the past 24 hours but
we still haven't heard about reported
deaths from the previous 96 hours so how
many deaths did alberta health record
between friday and monday
yeah so the those numbers will be
updated actually i think they're being
updated on the site as we speak um in
terms of the the other numbers for the
last four days so if you just go to the
site you can you can see them there and
they're being confirmed as we speak
thanks minister kevin follow-up
yeah i'm on the site and they're not
here um i'll keep checking but could you
elaborate a bit more on what the
technical issues are that your team's
facing
yeah so there is a detailed amount of
assessment that that
that
you know the teams that double check um
they were able to do it very quickly for
today's update uh for 24 hours uh but
doing over four day period uh my
understanding there's a significant
amount of work that to do that
my thought it was actually uh done and
they're updating it the site right right
now um but it should be done within uh
within uh the next few minutes uh and
we'll and then if not we can actually
get that to you through uh our press
secretary steve thank you
thanks minister i have thanks to the
callers there were just three today so
that wraps it up for today thanks again
minister thank you everyone and have a
great afternoon